foreign
[Music]
thank you
all right let's go ahead and open up the
door so hello and welcome everybody as
we are letting people into our live Zoom
room welcome to those who are here with
us live and if you are not live here
with us yet and would like to join us
feel free to go to daily with Doc
zoom.com all together of course that is
daily with Doc zoom.com my name is Becca
dukes and as the hostess of this program
I want to hide you for just a moment
there as the hostess of this program it
is my honor and privilege to make these
things that we will be talking about
today a resource that you can put in
your toolbox to arm yourself with
empowering information that you yourself
can take and Implement and feel the
positive results to a better health
Journey my name is Becca Dukes I am the
hostess of this program but I'm also the
director of student services for The
Institute of holistic health where we
have a certified holistic health coach
course that goes in deep when it comes
to
nutrient deficiencies how they affect
the four areas of health and not just
the problems folks but we address
Solutions Solutions are what's going to
get you to reach that Optimal Health
goal so I encourage you to go to
coachwithdoc.com that is coach with
spelled out d o c.com get more
information about our certified holistic
health coach course now we are a
resource to an amazing community of
certified holistic health coaches and
coaches and those that are just Health
advocates in wanting to spread the
message of Hope and what you yourself
can do when you
just put it upon yourself to realize
that you are worth investing in folks
health is simple
medical community wants to make it
difficult to make you think that you
have to have them in your life well
folks when you are being intentional and
making sure there's no deficiencies
within your own diet because food
it doesn't got it all you're going to
hear about that today
but being intentional and making sure
that you have the nutrition that your
body absolutely needs not just to barely
survive or survive or get through the
day with the help of a few
Pharmaceuticals but actually thrive on
its own with the help of using
Whole Foods as nutrition
but concentrated in the forms that
provide your complete daily allowance
and to bring that information to us I am
honored and privileged to be able to
offer to you one of the founding fathers
of the science of epigenetics whose
thesis actually is being held as a
national treasure in the Smithsonian
Museum
folks when you start researching and you
find things that are just mind-blowing
and changing
the way things are done
starting at the animal level is where Dr
Wallach was doing it and he even brought
back and be part of one of the biggest
conservation movements when it comes to
saving the White Rhino from Extinction
and now he just wants to save the world
so not just the animals but the humans
too
and that's what I love about this
program because we address both human
and animals alike
because Dr Wallach we're all created
right and if you are created
and you need
optimal substance to thrive then you got
to be intentional about it is that
correct Dr Wallach it is correct you
have to be proactive
proactive I like that word because I was
reactive Dr Wallach
it still worked
but to get to a point where you're 30
years old and the neurologist walks out
of his room thinking that he was going
in to see somebody 65 to 70 years old in
very poor health and I was actually a
fit 30 year old female on the outside
but the inside
he had to apologize
he's like and he asked me what are you
taking for pain
he says you have inflammation and
arthritis throughout the body you have
degenerative bone and disc disease plus
bone spurs
in addition to the compression fractures
of your spine
and
I cried I'm like
one
because I didn't realize that I was so
broken down inside
but then two because I finally had an
answer as to why I heard all over all
the time
but I didn't get a solution Dr Wallach
not for 12 more years 13 more years did
I find a solution when I heard you on
the radio so I am
I have a passion about providing to the
world your message because of the impact
that it made in my life
so everybody
Dr Joel Wallach Bachelor of Science in
agriculture
doctor of veterinarian medicine
three post doctorates and pathology a
naturopathic physician with so many
discoveries
and the underlying causes
and solutions
that have been positively impacting the
world but not in a way that they should
be folks
that is our job our job is to make sure
that this man's work and what you as an
empowered individual can do when you
take Health into your own hands
following the guidance of Dr Wallach who
is a pioneer
in the science of epigenetics and if you
don't know what epigenetics is
it is the science that proves the
genetic theory of disease transmission
to be incorrect
which if you have been told you have a
genetic disease
that should like flip a switch saying oh
I need to listen up to this because
folks we are turning that Light Of Hope
on for you today and today Dr Wallach
what do you have to share with us
because I well I kind of said it a
little bit I mean I had arthritis and
inflammation throughout my whole entire
body and Degen of bone and disc disease
so I think that might have something to
do with what you're going to be sharing
with us
well thank you very very much Rebecca
and thank you team it's one of those
things where this is uh you know
everybody has bones everybody has joints
everybody has cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue and
um it all goes south okay because it
needs constant nutrition I mean every
second it needs nutrition flowing to it
for this wonderful part of our our
bodies okay and
um just the cost of treating
osteoporosis just treating osteoporosis
symptoms
in three cultures the United States
Canada and Europe
cost each year a total of 6.5 trillion
US dollars
okay at 6 500 billion dollars
so I want to take a third of that
because we're a third of that population
so we'll take a third of that 2.3
okay 2.3 billion dollars okay 2.3
billion dollars
and we're going to add that to 626.8
billion dollars for premium arthritis
we're spending three trillion dollars a
year just to treat the symptoms of
arthritis and osteoporosis it's a very
simple nutritional deficiency disease
okay
and it's one of those things where
um is kind of like going back 3000 years
ago when there were plagues and people
didn't know anything about viruses and
bacteria back then and they knew that
evil spirits had gotten them whether
their enemies putting evil spirits on
them
no they they just had bad hygiene and
they were in a place where there was a
lot of people not practicing good
hygiene and so forth and somebody
brought a virus in there and everybody
was susceptible to it and everybody got
the virus and high death numbers and so
forth but three thousand years ago they
knew it was a terrible
a terrible terrible
um bad
um
so he put a bad spell on them
okay they knew it was an evil spirit
but because they didn't know anything
about nutrition they didn't know
anything about bacteria and viruses and
fungus and yeast and stuff like that
well we're in another one of those
junctures okay let's say three trillion
dollars a year we're spending just to
treat the symptoms of arthritis
osteoporosis America who could end all
that just think if we could use that
three trillion dollars
for educating our kids better food so we
can add 10 15 20 more years for our life
wouldn't it be worth it well of course
it is and so that's why we work so hard
and I can't thank Rebecca and her team
enough
it's just one of those things where we
are working so hard and of course
um we got Cheryl Marley and and Paul
croteau from from the um
um
from The Institute from The Institute
right from The Institute
and so it's one of those things where
we have to pay attention to this okay so
here we go we require 90 essential
nutrients
we require 90 Cent Solutions now if you
take 89 of them you're going to have a
problem
if you're only taking out of the 90 if
you're only taking 50 you're going to
have a real problem these are the people
with 15 diseases they're going to 14
different Specialists but insurance pays
for it so they don't mind
of course the doctors love their
patients okay and so it's one of those
things where we do have a program for
osteoporosis and arthritis and the
original simple Farm was called the
healthy bone joint pack which is our
Healthy Start pack which has a 90
essential nutrients 60 minerals 16
vitamins 12 minutes to Three fatty acids
and our glucose gel which is our first
um
uh what did she say yeah that was her
first effort to to get um collagen uh
into people okay and we call it a
glucogel okay and then we came up with
collagen peptides which has four
different sources of collagen okay and
so we've we've come a long way and we
deal you know for instance um Theo
Ratliff great great basketball player I
met him many years ago when he was only
24 years old
and a you know seven foot something you
know and he had terrible bone to bone
arthritis in his knees the doctors want
to give him a double knee replacement uh
he had the cartilage coming off his hips
he had a fracture of his shooting arm
wrist and the Atlanta Hawks he was
playing for and he actually got his
contract taken away from the kicked him
out because he didn't want to have
surgery oh smart okay so we rebuilt him
okay we had one of his
um but he's who we had already treated
for osteoporosis and arthritis and so
forth and so together we got um
theoretical of repaired and healed in
about three months he came back and he
got on another big contract he made a
hundred million dollars in 11 years
now you know here you're just taking
that money and run but basically what he
did he took at least a half of that and
bought this big
Institute a big institution like kind of
a college on a big big uh area land area
and he makes it available for free to
kids from the poor communities
okay
who want to get into health and sports
and all this kind of stuff and he gets
them on the right track nutrition wise
health-wise education wise and so forth
and so we're so very proud to associate
with Theo Ratliff because the way he
turned out when he made all that money
he could have taken it run but he
decided to
put it back into the community and so we
can't thank him enough for that
okay so just think about that
three trillion dollars were spent a year
just to treat the symptoms of honesty
approaches and arthritis all of which
are
repeatable and reversible for
essentially
dollars a day okay this is we're just
talking about dollars as opposed to
trillions okay this is this is so easy
and of course then another one another
one um Evander Holyfield great
heavyweight boxing champion uh he lost
his heavy championship to Michael Moore
and he couldn't answer the Bell and the
last round of his defending his title
and he lost by default cause he had a
heart attack he couldn't it was the same
thing that was causing sediment death
syndrome and kids under the age of three
months of age right and so he had the
same heart attack so he came up with a
healthy Brandon heart pack for him and
he got him going on that and after six
months of that he came back and there
had been several changes in the in the
in the um people who had become champion
of the heavyweights after Michael Moore
had got it by default and um uh Emmanuel
Holyfield had to fight Mike Tyson one of
the meanest most aggressive of all the
heavyweight champions ever and in the
sixth round the referees had to stop the
fight because
Evander Holyfield was going to kill Mike
Tyson Mike Tyson's arms were down to the
side and he was not defending himself
and Evander Holyfield was hitting with
everything I think he had and the the
um referees recognizers and a big
problem here so they jumped in and
stopped the fight and uh he got his
championship back and it's all because
of the healthy Bone and Joint attack
okay so these things were made for
Champions and the Champions delivered
and so this is why we tell those stories
and we have a flip chart coming out with
their stories in them the slip chart has
the stories of many many famous people
okay and we're talking about
um also uh Danny Glover we're talking
about Pat Boone we're talking about
Martin Luther King III and I could go on
and on and on but you get the drill here
okay Pastor Mike Freeman uh these are
stories it'll blow your mind all because
they took the 90 essential nutrients
this is very very simple stuff these are
unimpeachable
people these are not somebody's who live
on the street these are very well to do
people in the community both financially
and stationed okay and
um you know they could have demanded a
lot of money to tell their story they're
telling their story for free because
they really appreciated the fact that we
charged them nothing for our time and
information and of course they just paid
wholesale prices for their products
there you go
so with that
um I'm very very excited about this I
can't thank you Becca and her team
enough for putting all this together
it's one of those things where
um we uh we have many many more healings
coming up
um we have uh if there's a bunch more
new ones coming up in the slip chart and
of course Rebecca told you about the
epigenetics book uh the book um Rare
Earth being cures that that book rare
has been cures was compiled completely
out of that big project that Dr Milan
and I did in China 1 200 autopsies okay
and and kids on the age of 10 and we
figured out a lot of stuff and it's it's
all in that book Rare Earth Wind and
cures the reference to all that is in
the book epigenetics and the references
under W for Wallach okay and it'll blow
your mind that all this came from the
study in China okay and so we we have a
history that's different from anybody
just going to a local
College okay we have a history that's
different uh 21 million dollar Grant
okay to Washington University in St
Louis did 20 000 autopsies there
uh my thesis is in the Smithsonian
Institute as a National Treasure because
they showed there were no genetic
disease or no autoimmune diseases all
this information is available for you
for literally pennies
okay for the for the price of these
books and CDs and things like that you
get this information instead of
thousands or Millions you're paying
pennies okay for the information and
you'll pay wholesale for the products
and
um you know if you become one of our
Associates and you know get trained and
help other people we will pay you
we will pay you okay and so that's why
we love the health coaches they went in
there just because they wanted to help
people and so we found a way to be able
to support them financially okay and
through all the efforts of Rebecca and
and um
Carol Morley and Paul kroto and uh Dr
Milan and many many other people okay so
we're very very proud to put all this
together make it available and this
five-star general in the deal is Rebecca
Rebecca you're on
well I can't be the five-star general
because is there anything about
five-star general doc
um God
okay so God is up here and then you as a
five-star general I'll take two three
four star general okay because you are
you are the leader and you are the one
Dr Wallach that has done all of the
research and you started this movement
this crusade to get this information out
so that people can obtain it
and folks for Dr wallach's books go to d
r j wallick.com that is d r j w a l l a
c
h.com now Dr Wallach you were mentioning
Mike Tyson and Evander Holyfield
and
I would probably be beating somebody
beat the pulp out of them too if they
bit a chunk of my ear off and then bit
me again
just because
just saying and then Theo Ratliff and
the Family Resource Center that he has
built that is just really making a
positive impact in his community is
absolutely fantastic for for just a
resource and and a place to go where
people can feel loved and get what they
need in order to to better survive so
these are just that right there he's
just one person that has done some
incredible things
because of
what Dr Wallach has brought into his
life and the life that has been brought
in back
and at this point you're right on cue
and I'll throw one other thing in there
um we got rid of
CIS of brosis thought to be the most
terrible Birds effect of afflicting
human being sought to be a genetic thing
we proved that wrong when we got rid of
it okay with our lawsuits getting the
nutrition into baby Farmers we also got
rid of mustard Dystrophy and when we
gave all that information to Jerry Lewis
um the Kerry Lewis's program okay
Jerry's kids and through the through his
um events he would have every year okay
he raised 2.6
2.6 billion dollars
was a billion or trillion
billion yeah 2.6 billion dollars okay
for the research from us yesterday
and when we gave Jerry Lewis the cause
of engine cure much history he was so
excited because he talked to a dozen
families and doctors and we were able to
prove it to him and this was 2011.
um September 4th he goes and he tells
the the
um most of the association we had found
the cause of energy cure much history
the fire Jerry Lewis summarily they put
a gag order on him so he couldn't say
anything to anybody or the press or
anything and then the next day on the
5th of September 2011 they shut down the
Telethon after he had raised 2.6 billion
dollars for them
how's that for a thank you okay
goes to prove Dr Wallach that it's it's
hard to know who
you can trust and whenever there's a
dollar being attached to any type of
event
and raising money to find a cure what
happens when the Cure is found
they no longer need money to find it
so do they really want to find
a cure well you should want to find a
cure because they'll still need some
money to educate people you know to have
classes and travel around give classes
so it won't be as much but they'll still
need some money to to go on and carry
the message out there so everybody knows
and the third thing that we did in that
same program
um we found the cause and prevention of
suddenly death syndrome all these heart
attacks these young athletes are having
now okay Simon's death syndrome
um is the same cause of a heart attack
okay as they're having now these young
athletes and we put these nutrients in
the baby formula send them a death
syndrome went away just like in 90 days
it went away no more new cases okay
because it was in the baby formula now
and doctors had fought it for years or
25 years it prevented us from putting
all these minerals in the baby forms all
those minerals are poisonous you can't
put them into the baby Farmers well we
put we actually sued the FDA
in federal court eight times John
Seymour my great attorney and I and we
prevailed everyone eight times we've got
all these nutrients into the baby
Farmers we ended
cesarosis muscular industry and cinnamon
death syndrome all because we put these
nutrients into the baby formulas so
we're very very very proud of that and
the whole team because we needed to
build an army and we were successful
well and what about the work that you
did with retired Navy SEAL Marvin Rock
Dr Wallach and muscular dystrophy oh
yeah Marvin Rob was involved with that
and it was great in Indiana Idaho Utah
um let's see here Washington State
uh and the Northern California and also
in uh see Washington and
let's just south of Washington
Oregon Oregon
Washington Oregon and Northern
California uh Indiana Idaho Utah Marvin
Rob this Navy SEAL I mean he was
tireless so he just and he was there for
two reasons one to protect us because
there were people coming
and trying to
disrupt our meetings and you know
destroy our products and everything
there and so we had this Navy SEAL guy
there who was able to pick them up by
their belt and throw them out of the
door and so and so he was helping us
physically uh being able to perform and
do our job but also he was talking with
so many families
and uh you know he he came from a
farming background so he's able to talk
with these farmers and he had the
respect of being a Navy SEAL and he we
still worked together he still still is
one of our great resources for help and
so yeah Marvin Robb is with it that's
for sure
well there's something about those Navy
guys Dr Wallach but I do my hats off to
all that have served in the military
thank you everyone for your service and
Dr Wallach you also as you have served
in the U.S Air Force and also the army
I retired lieutenant colonel in the Air
Force yes so thank you so much again for
your service and I have been corrected
okay thanks AJ
um alvander Holyfield was already
beating the pants off of Mike Tyson
which is the reason why he was bit
more than once so
let's go to um helping people
nutritionally Dr Wallach so they can
also control
um their mental health and physical
health and everything in between
the first question that I have and folks
um if you are here live with us and you
would like to ask a question go to that
Zoom menu and click raise hand you'll
probably find it in the re response
under the response Tab and then there is
a place that you can raise hand I will
be calling on people in the order that
their hand was received I know I've
gotten some private messages saying hey
I can't unmute there is a reason for
that
um we want to make sure that we keep
some structure and we don't try to talk
over each other so please raise your
hand if you are out on YouTube or rumble
or Facebook or anything that is
associated with Spotify where we're
broadcasting out from there including
uh truth and I'm not going to try to
mention them on there's there's so many
AJ's doing just a fantastic job and
getting getting us out there
but go ahead and you can comment in the
comments there as well but most
importantly make sure that you uh save
us subscribe to our Channel send us love
and send somebody else love by sharing
our program with somebody that you love
and care about or if you don't love and
care about anybody just share it anyways
because
just helping one little person in this
world
is where it all starts
so as we're reaching hundreds thousands
and millions around the world Dr Wallach
we are part of this Crusade together
this first question that I have Dr
Wallach is coming
um from someone here in the zoom with us
and
forgive me I lost the name but her
husband has kid uh Kennedy's disease
which is said to be a rare inherited
narrow muscular disorder that causes
Progressive weakening and wasting of the
muscles particularly in the arms and
legs other major symptoms include severe
cramps and problems with speech and
swallowing
and the disease progresses slowly and
the life expectancy is usually normal so
Deanna
um are you available to come on oh
wonderful you have your hand up thank
you so much Deanna go ahead and unmute
yourself
actually what I'm gonna do is put my
husband on he's the one with candidates
what's the name of the disease
and Kennedy's disease
okay
and it's trouble swallowing muscle
wasting correct yes now does he have any
rain in his ears ever complain about
ringing his ears
um right now yeah I have uh okay how
many times a night does he wake up to
urinate once three times five times
you know monks
okay
does he have any troubles he said does
he have trouble swallowing and talking
does his voice changed
no my voice hasn't changed uh swallowing
yeah I'm swallowing it a little bit
um but mostly in the legs weakening
oh okay
all right
and how old is your husband how much
does he weigh
back into MDOC yeah what do you weigh
50 59 and Away about 165
okay 165 pounds in your and you're 69
years old you know 59 oh 59 okay all
right
and uh do you have any balance problems
or you have to use a cane or a walker
yes okay all right you have osteoporosis
of the skull has your doctor told you
that
no you've osteoporosis of the skull we
actually have a book and a CD set
okay it's called it's all in your head
and you have classic examples the ninth
cranial nerve the glossopharyngeal nerve
is impacted I actually approaches a
skull would you open those up those
pages six page number six uh the top
skull here both of these are an autopsy
the top skull on the top of the skull
has been removed you're looking down on
the brain and you see the skull is only
acquirement is sick the bottom skull
okay is it autopsy the top of the skull
has been removed you're looking down on
the brain but the skull is an inch and a
half to two inches thick you can see
where that would impact and squeeze the
12 pairs of cranial nerves and impact
and squeeze this spinal cord
the uh do you have any regular heartbeat
or a fast heart rate or so heart rate
anything like that uh Jazz sometimes
okay sometimes it does fast rate
yeah
or irregular heartbeat afib atrial
fibrillation
um yes okay yes I heard a yes there okay
yeah well that's the tenth cranial nerve
the Vegas nerve being squeezed by the
brain the ninth cranial nerve causes the
stuff for the throat and the tongue and
the swallowing that kind of stuff the
dizziness and balance problems is the
atrial nerve being squeezed
okay and there's a chapter in this book
for each of the of the cranial nerves it
goes into all the various issues you get
when that cranial nerve is being
squeezed by the skull okay doctors do
not get trained this in school and so we
decided about two years ago to come out
with his book and CD set and so that's
between myself and Dr Milan and Rebecca
the three of us put together the book of
a CD set
and so it's one of those things where
this information is available to us just
for a few dollars okay but if you don't
do deal with this yourself
your insurance company is going to spend
millions of dollars on you okay you see
you end this picture here uh all the
nerves going out to cranders going out
to the different organs go to the back
of the book where it shows from from the
brain all the way down
I think page 27 or something like that
there you go everything south of the
skull
you get you get numbness and tingling in
your toes okay
okay when you have the balance problems
that's the vestibular branch of the
atrial nerve being squeezed okay uh
let's see here do you have any
respiratory problems any any that kind
of stuff
he gets pneumonia really easy and he
also has hearing problems
has hearing problems okay yeah yeah
that's the auditory branch of the atrium
that are being squeezed but you look at
everything you have all these nerves
being squeezed by your skull affects
everything below your skull your
urination rate at night
um during the daytime of respiration
heart rate
um where they're going to get pain and
stuff like that in your arms and your
fingers and your legs and your hips your
back that's all caused by obviously
approaches to the skull and doctors
don't deal with that at all so that's
why we came up with a book in the CD set
and right now it's one of our more
popular book sales okay because nobody's
ever heard that your doctors never
talked to you about us you're supposed
to say oh no well you need to get this
book and after you read it and you might
want to
I would loan it to your doctor but get a
deposit from them so if he doesn't give
it back to you you keep the money okay
buy you another one buy another one and
so hiccups is also caused by a branch of
the 10th cranial nerve being squeezed
get the hiccups people say I don't know
why doctors want to do surgery and cut
nerves and everything oh just try my
program here you know give me 90 days
and invariably they never have to have
the surgery because within 90 days we
can rebuild the skull goes back to
normal with a nice nutritional
supplement program okay and so this is
very very easy to deal with again uh at
165 pounds give it all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed Meats no oils
no glutens no Wheaton around oats no
buckwheat no sugar no carbonated drinks
even the diet drinks got to go and no
carbonated water because they neutralize
stomach acid so you cannot absorb
um minerals are digest food we do want
you to get a hold of that book Dr Walsh
cooking out the bad foods there's 300
pages of safe recipes and cooking that
has all the good food bad food lists in
there okay sorry household needs one of
those books doctor always cooking out
the bad foods and then the book and CD
said it's all in your head
we're talking about 37 different
diseases that your doctor is going to
send you to his classmates
okay you have the ringing in the ears
and melons problems oh he'll send you
his even throws a no doctor they'll give
you hearing aids
okay when it's really actually
approaches to the skull they know
nothing about that and so this is
something where all those autopsies
they've done all those years we did
complete autopsy we didn't just open it
up and look at the appendix I mean we
looked at every bone in the body we did
X-rays I mean it was something like
crazy we're finding things that nobody
had ever heard of okay because we did
complete autopsies on every one of those
and of course
we we learn a lot by saving a white
rhino there's only 650 when I'm Excuse
me 350 yeah only 350 when I went to
Africa uh spent two years there and we
came up with a system and now there's 21
000 we're very very proud of that we can
do the same thing with Humanity we can
and we've all we did was give them their
vitamins and minerals and water and
stuff like that and they survived and
did well when we just did the very very
basic stuff for the White Rhino and so
this is what we're learning to do for
Humanity and every time we do for
Humanity what we did for the White Rhino
we did correct and of course the book on
the White Rhino is called Rhino Express
that's great for kids who want to get
into conservation or work in zoos and
things like that Rhino Express
tells the story of the White Rhino
project we did for two years and
um South Africa and the unfalosian Shish
Louis game reserves okay back to you
Rebecca
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
and Rhino Express I mean this is a great
little Adventure book so if you have any
uh children at heart or by age this
would be a great gift to give
um just going through Dr wallach's
Adventure was saving the white rhino
so I want to make sure that everybody
knows that folks Dr Wallach is going
through these these protocols and these
recommendations fairly quickly if you
are working with somebody already and
they share this program with you make
sure that you get back with them and say
hey I was able to ask Dr Wallach my
question
on this date
I need some help getting the products
that he mentioned
and then refer them to our one of our
critical Health news uh channels whether
it's YouTube or Facebook we have the
recordings that are there
right away so that you can then re-watch
them we also have some of them on our
well almost all of them except for like
the last couple days on our website
daily with doc.com now on daily
withdoc.com we do have a newsletter so
when you sign up for our newsletter and
you have a question that you would like
to ask feel free to ask it there and let
us know if you are working with somebody
already let us know weight age height
the major conditions that you are
interested in and also if you are on on
any Pharmaceuticals that are quote
unquote controlling something that you
just don't realize you still have the
symptoms are masked so let us know those
things and we will make sure that we get
Dr wallach's recommendations to you
um and those we read on air too so we
will
get back to you now Dr willick
um
let me go to Robert who has a question
for you Robert go ahead and unmute
hello Robert how can we help you
Robert I'm asking you to unmute there
you go
can you say something can we hear you
yeah
there we go
okay
um Rob he also typed in his questions
here Dr Wallach
um so one is you talk about not
consuming sugar
and he wants to know why is there so
much Stevia and fructose in many of the
products including the nine grams of
sugar in the rebound product
okay well rebound product is for energy
for athletes and how are you going to
get your car to run at the at the races
okay you need to put gasoline in it and
if you want to compete with all these
other athletes you do need some fuel
okay when you're in a competition so we
do have sugar in something that's meant
to give you energy for fuel to compete
with somebody who's trying to beat you
okay and so that's why there's a lot of
and of course we only have like 25 of
the sugar that's in Red Bull Red Bull
has a lot of sugar in it okay Red Bull
only has one mineral magnesium we have
75 minerals there's 75 Metals better
than one metal yeah okay and we only
have like 25 percent of the caffeine
that Red Bull has so Red Bull gives you
energy by giving you caffeine and sugar
we give you energy by giving your organs
and muscles and hearts and lungs
everything they need to work properly
that's what that's why we have the 75
minerals and 25 volumes amino acids in
our score strength rebound totally
different man we actually made the
rebound for again for Theo Ratliff when
he was when he came back we rebuilt him
with the healthy Bone and Joint pack it
was very obvious you know he was playing
his heart out and so he came up with
um the rebound for him and it became
such a great product uh and so um that's
why we have it but our sugar is like 25
and what's in a Red Bull
our caffeine is 25 of what's in Red Bull
but we have 75 minutes that Red Bull
only has one mineral magnesium
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
for that explanation let's go to Phyllis
who has her hand up Phyllis go ahead and
unmute yourself please
Dr Wallach we have a couple of questions
on YouTube about the kidneys
uh we have a woman who is 58 and she
says her creatine is 1.7 with a GFR of
and she is wondering how accurate are
blood tests in determining kidney
function
well the blood tests are determining
kidney function are correct okay it's a
it's a scientific thing that's well
documented and so forth
um and it's just it's kind of like a
monitor it's like using a thermometer to
you know to maintain to keep checking
your temperature kind of thing okay you
can't deny the results but you can't
you're not necessarily going to tell
what's causing the problems by using a
thermometer okay you don't know if it's
a virus or you have your hand in the
oven you know you don't know what's
going on there but you do know there's
an issue okay
yeah so so we need some more information
in other words regarding particular
symptoms yeah
does she have a diagnosis does she have
a fibromyalgia does she have a
cardiomopathy does she have kidney
failure uh if she has kidney failure uh
that's easy to deal with okay
we have
um the uh let's see here I like the the
healthy brain and heart pack the MSM uh
take three of those twice a day I like
the ultimate daily classic challenge
take three of those twice a day for 100
pounds of body weight if you have a
kidney issue and when you have high
blood pressure or not but it will
support healthy blood flow through
blocked arteries including the brain and
the heart and the kidneys and when you
have blocked arteries in the kidneys
you're going to get high blood pressure
almost always have a pressure associated
with that and so the ultimate daily
classic tablets are designed to support
and promote maintenance repair of
cartilage limous tendons connective
tissue but also to deal with the the
blood pressure and blood blood flows
through blocked arteries I take people
that haven't urinated in 10 years they
have not urinated in 10 years or in
Dallas so six days a week okay we put
them on our program okay which includes
the rebound includes the ultimate daily
classic tablets includes the uh healthy
brain and heart pack includes the MSM
and and say a couple of weeks time
suddenly now they're urinating after 10
years and not urinate so they drop the
dialysis from six days a week to three
days a week and in two more weeks you're
totally off of dialysis okay and they
were totally on dialysis for 25 years
the last 10 years of which are they were
on six days a week okay and so if we
know what the problem is we have a
program to deal with it nutritionally
okay rather than do kidney transplants
and all that kind of stuff or milk the
insurance company by putting you on the
dialysis for 25 years you got to be
kidding me okay then he says somebody
should have gone to jail for that one
okay she does have stage three kidney
disease so it sounds as though what you
mentioned is the perfect protocol for
that yes exactly it is okay so you know
keep in contact with us because people
want to know whatever happened to you
know that uh person
that uh
okay and we also have another question
about uh urine color and how does that
indicate how the kidneys are working
what is a so-called good color and I
know that when people start taking the
products often they notice that their
urine turns bright yellow and they
wonder what does that indicate so if you
could talk a little bit about urine
color and how that relates to Kidney
Health well the urine color could be
something like beta-carotene for me lots
of carrots and yellow vegetables and
stuff like that so beta-carotene is
coming through okay and so that's where
that yellow color comes from and it's
nothing to be alarmed about okay
um but you do want to you go to a
pharmacy without a prescription and get
urine test strips okay and
test your own urine and see if there's
any blood or anything like that in there
that would be of concern you know if you
had blood in there but it's just a year
in the color of yellow that's urine is
um most of the time yellow if your urine
is clear that means you don't have an
overflow of things you should have an
overflow in you know you need a lot of
stuff
and so you want to have a lot of stuff
so it's your urine does have a little
bit of color to it
I wonder if someone is not drinking
enough water
um and the urine is dark could that mean
that person is dehydrated
well
um again that's another issue and of
course to determine that you need to get
blood pressure uh you need to do a
urinalysis you need blood chemistry you
know blood test
and that'll tell you if you're being
dehydrated
okay and so the kidney issues the
kidneys people don't know this but the
kidneys well if it doesn't feel like
it's getting enough blood to clean
because this job is to clean your blood
that's why it make sure it's all the bad
stuff can come out with the urine that's
the purpose urine is to pee out the bad
stuff right it's a vessel to to urinate
on the bad stuff out of your body
and so when when it comes to
um
kidneys your kidneys if they if your
kidney doesn't feel like it's doing its
job he'll release a hormone to cause
your blood pressure to go up
makes your blood pressure go up so you
get more blood being driven into the
kidneys
so it can make more urine to pee out
more bad stuff
okay so that's kind of the process
people don't know that you're
um all the time many times your high
blood pressure is due to your kidneys
pumping out that hormone
that is great to know thank you back to
you Becca
all right thank you Phyllis great great
questions coming from our YouTube
um audience and I know that the woman
with the kidney failure Dr Wallach she
states that she got off dialysis after
three months after following your
dietary advice and her failure was due
to
um a pharmaceutical
stage three kidney failure
well folks I was reminded that the
content of this program is to provide
nutritional education only it is not
meant to take the place of your primary
care physician and our products are not
meant to treat diagnose or cure any
diseases as empowered individuals though
folks we have options available and
that's what you're hearing about today
let's go to the next town that is up Dr
Wallach and I want to do a shout out and
thank you to Michelle because our first
question of the day was because she
referred them to our program so thank
you so much Michelle go ahead and unmute
yourself
all right hello
this is for me I'm a female 62 130
pounds 4 foot 11 type 1 diabetes for 55
years uh before I started the nutrition
four years ago
stopped there stopped there for a minute
how old were you when they diagnosed you
as type 1 diabetes
uh seven it was seven years old okay and
you had no problems until then and
suddenly now you're a type 1 diabetic
yeah well I can tell you it happened
after I got the dtp vaccine
okay
my symptoms started okay and so they put
you on insulin
yep and so have you been under control
since then
oh yeah in fact I've only gone into
diabetic ketoacidosis once in my life
so yeah
okay have you tried our program for
diabetes I've been doing it yeah I've
been doing it for four years now Okay
good
does it help you with yes blood sugar
yep I just want to get off all of it if
I can I don't know if it's possible
well type 1 diabetes is when Mama was
missing stuff when your pancreas was
forming when you're an embryo in her
body
and you didn't get enough beta cells in
the in the islands of lanyard hand to
make insulin usually they can tell when
you're born because they test for that
right away they take a blood sample from
your umbilical cord and they test for
type 1 diabetes right away because
that's how doctors send their kids to
college you can find somebody with type
1 diabetes because their babies are born
with it okay rarely does it appear later
in life okay I get people
they say I I was just diagnosed with
type 1 diabetes well how old are you I'm
65 years old did you ever have diabetes
for you know I go in every year from
annual physical and everything is fine
but now this year they said I got type 1
diabetes okay well somebody is either
mistaken stupid or lying because you
don't get type 1 diabetes when you're 65
years old you're born with it okay it's
a that is a issue it's not a genetic
thing but it is an issue because it's a
birth defect because mama was missing
stuff when the beta cells are being
formed and the Alex langerhan that
produce insulin okay so they're missing
because he didn't have the stuff to give
the baby to farm them okay
so I apologize I interrupted you we only
got a moment here so
what's the next one
yeah so I'm I'm doing much better I went
from taking 65 units a day now I take
about 23. yeah
excellent well do keep us informed okay
and um you know you got a great story so
you know call in you know on occasion
and let us know what's going on because
other people uh with uh true type 1
diabetes are going to want to know what
you're doing because that's going to
help them and then just toll free so it
doesn't cost you any other little time
so we appreciate you doing that okay
thank you
Michelle was there something that you
were you were asking about yourself so
you've already worked on the type 1
diabetes was there something else that
you are wanting some recommendations for
uh no I was just hoping that maybe there
was a miracle that could happen here
well we'll find out because if you're a
true type 1 diabetes you don't have any
cells making insulin so you're gonna
have to be on the sweeties you know
forever okay
yeah and I think I do because sometimes
when I'm in a state of euphoria where
I'm super excited my blood sugar is
plummet so that's not typical for type 1
and so and I was always pegged at
brittle diabetic because they'd go up
and down depending on my mood and
how's that possible with a true type one
yep okay we'll stay with the sweeties
through those twice a day to your body
weight and that's going to help you
regulate your blood sugar so you don't
have high ups and low Downs okay
all right thank you
okay thank you Michelle yeah we're gonna
have to go here
um and now Dr Wally
we just want to thank you so much for
joining us today and being part of daily
with Doc you are amazing and we
appreciate you Dr Wallach okay thank you
thank you all right bye for now
all right and thank you everybody I know
we didn't get to all the hands all the
questions up we do apologize for that
um if we did not get to your question
please reach out to us through our
website daily with doc.com or you may
also uh come and join us back tomorrow
as we are here Monday through Friday
from 12 to 12 50 p.m Pacific time that
is Monday through Friday from 12 to 12
50 p.m Pacific Time most Mondays through
Fridays now Dr Wallach is getting back
on the road so there are going to be
some a few days that we will not be
having our live Zoom like August 24th
and 25th are the next dates that we will
be off the air for dailywood Doc so just
heads up I just found that out yesterday
crew so I'm letting you know now if I
could get my crew on with me I am
surrounded by some amazing co-hosts that
helped me make this program possible we
have Phyllis Anderson who is joining us
um from the Vegas area and she's just
been very instrumental in her and her
husband Andy I won't forget you Andy a
very been very instrumental in getting
Dr Wallach on the Airways so we thank
you so much for that and we have sherry
who is a health coach and has
certifications from multiple different
organizations giving her that
acknowledgment that she knows her stuff
folks including the Institute of
holistic health and as a certified
holistic health coach which all of the
people on my crew we've got one that's
almost there but everybody has gone
through the certified holistic health
coach course and
um has or will soon be receiving their
certification as a certified holistic
health coach
gaining the knowledge
that is needed to truly share Dr
wallach's message and his
recommendations and his recommendations
are the solutions that we use for health
we have Albert who is
way down south in South Africa folks and
bringing it to us um his his knowledge
and passion to help people around the
world so we just want to welcome him to
our team as he is our newest member of
the team not the newest one as far as
coaches within my organization but
to this team here that we have with us
and we have Ruth Ellen Sanchez who is my
executive production manager who has
been with me for three years over three
years in bringing Dr Wallach to zoom and
just making this program and other
programs available to you as a resource
so thank you Ruth Allen for all that you
have done over the years and helping to
put this team together and do the
training and make it all happen and then
we also have Coach Rod who is coming
from us newly retired and rehired
himself folks as a full-time coach in
also helping us with the whole
production of our program here on daily
with Doc and also
AJ who is the assistant production
manager and being very instrumental in
doing the leg work and what is needed
that I did not have time for and Ruth
Ellen didn't have time for in getting us
out onto multiple platforms every single
one of these individuals are doing a
major part in making this production
successful whether it's Marilyn who is
doing an amazing job with dictation for
those of you who are live here in the
zoom with us and you have that chat
option open she's doing dictation when
she's not here Phyllis is doing
dictation which she's also adding value
into that chat and helping people get
the whole picture
it's not about one thing not about
this thing folks we're not into
fractionization we're into the whole
body the whole picture and they both are
sharing information so I want to thank
Marilyn for all she does and
all the research that she does too
because she she keeps things interesting
and and adds value there
if you have a passion for people
or even if you just have a passion for
yourself and you're tired of being sick
and tired
then folks you're in the right place get
with the person that shared this program
with you
ask them about what it is that you
specifically need to meet your specific
needs to help create a better health
Journey if you're not working with
anybody and you would like to be coached
by a certified holistic health coach for
those that have not reached out or been
reached out to in regards to Dr Wallach
youngevity or any of the products
or even this program
then we are offering a free 15-minute
consultation
for those who go to daily withdoc.com
and request one use that contact option
on our website daily withdoc.com and
request your free 15-minute consultation
we also have an 800 number
855-949-3377 that's
855-949-3377 again this is for people
only who are not already working with
somebody
we are a resource for an amazing
community
if you have already started working with
somebody get back with them
all right they took the time to share
this program with you they have the
ability to help you and if they don't
they know the resources to get that help
to make sure that they are directing you
to get the products that are needed for
your specific situation
um and we're gonna be doing something a
little bit new so folks if you're
watching us on any platform
any platform
put some comments in that com in those
comments ask your questions we are going
to be monitoring those very closely and
we are going to be doing some Raffles
and drawings and even a grand prize for
some products to the most active people
who are
spreading the word sharing our program
with others and just helping us to make
an impact while we are on this Crusade
so the brilliant idea of Mr AJ
um
it's gonna cost me some money but you
know what folks you are worth it
you are worth figuring out what it is
that might be missing within your own
body
and it's worth it to me
to help make an impact in your life
through nutrition
so there you go
get ready I'm ready to watch I'm I know
AJ and Ruth Ellen and Rod they're all
ready to watch too as for the month of
August on August 31st we're gonna do a
review and start holding possibly even
monthly drawings
so until next time my name is Becca
Dukes give back with the person that
shared this program with you and if
there is nobody to think we have an
amazing team here for you
did I forget anything I love you too
storks
you're shaking your head Ruth Ellen what
did I forget
did you mention fabulous Sherry
oh I did quickly
oh yeah Sherry Sherry's amazing she does
have those I did
she has the multiples okay my mistake
yeah no I think I got everybody
um
and yeah so as a Hostess of this program
and the director of student services for
The Institute of holistic health and Dr
wallach's personal assistants
it is my honor and privilege to bring
this program to you
and until next time
bye for now
I've got to get somebody else to end the
meeting it always gets hidden
there
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign